stoney stoney baloney
avery eyes up here dude sorry you get
caught up dude
there is a another
person who's gonna be joining us named
adam ill
who's the high one
you oh damn it
liquid death he drinks that's incredible
look at myself
was that freaky just to pop in like that
like you're just sitting there
wow
i heard you're talented on the keys
thank you kindly
maybe we could collab one day with a
little piano with some flute
that's hurt wait
when did you start playing the flute
what
kind of does that mean this is a little
quick little trivia
what is the new name of the buffalo bill
stadium
no wait hi mark
[Music]
okay
this is like a normal highlight you know
but tonight adam
[Music]
it's like the mushrooms were a little
our extra mushroomy i think
[Laughter]
but this mixture the shrooms and the
weed tonight is like
gorgeous truly gorgeous dude
it's just got me
[__] motion i've started a lot of
sentences in my head or i'm like nah
that's a
i can't i don't know
this one works in the garden yeah he
he searches for seeds he's a seed
separator so he's around a lot of soil
and
and leaves so that's right you got the
perfect size fingers for seed separation
i got like a man hand right here like
working nine to five and you got to
shop in nine to five by the way we are
giving away baby hands tonight
you guys know that there is
yo you're making me nervous now
avery where's your where's your baby
hand
i don't have a woman i don't have a baby
that's all right man we still like you
at parts of this tonight my brother will
[__] you
if if i can breathe thc instead of
oxygen i would
yeah i know i know that to be true this
is
liquid death expensive you're thirsty do
you feel like you're in the middle of it
all
yeah i'm in the middle of the bottom
here
[Music]
what year was running water introduced
into the white house how about that how
was that
wait where was
what year was running water introduced
that was a totally different [__]
impersonation than the first one
that was like right that was you
actually trying to get a roll
that was an audition okay good now we're
back and engaged
all right let me do it again please
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right all right all right ready
what year was running water this is
really just my voice
that's what i'm saying you're delivering
an audition
you're going what year wow
[Music]
what's up brother hey sean have you ever
tasted breast milk
[__] yeah i was actually about to have
some cereal
but there wasn't enough milk so uh
can i tell you something can i tell you
something really funny awesome because
that's are really funny
is i drifted off
i almost made bagels as uh i only got
good at making bagels for like two weeks
and then
josh like everything bagels of course
everything that was done the bake is on
[Music]
you